no no she's me she got a black heart she
does not why do you always side with her
well she is my mother and there it is
there's a problem you should be siding
with me
over brisket it's not just brisket the
way she's been treating me since day one
comes some kind of loser booby prize
booby prize what was that
georgie you mind your own business
what did i do
what's going on
mom and dad are fighting
what about
brisket
if they get a divorce who do you think
you'll pick to live with
oh mom of course i want mom pick again
i thought dad was coming no he had work
to do what kind of work i don't know
coaching stuff can he do it after the
picnic no missy he cannot why not
enough how come george is not going
he's grounded for eavesdropping on me
and your father
well i hope he learned his lesson
is this about the recipe
i bet he's mad cause you always side
with me mom
and how would you know that
george you told me
are you and dad getting a divorce course
not
well if you do i want to live with you
sheldon no one's getting a divorce
but thank you honey
you know this all goes away if you just
give him your recipe for the brisket i
know
and i guess it's not going away
i wasn't eavesdropping
don't worry about it i just don't see
why i got grounded what are you
complaining about you don't wanna go
church picnic anyway i like complaining
i'm good at it
i'll be right back
mind if i have a sip of your beer you
mind if i dip your head in the compost
heap
you could have just said no
[Music]
what are you doing
nothing get out of here
you're looking for a brisket recipe all
sudden you got smart i said get out of
here i won't tell i swear
all right help me look
mmm found it no this is our french toast
not looking for french toast
she does make it good though did you
know she puts vanilla extract in her
whipped cream i did not
quarter teaspoon georgie
yeah we're looking for brisket
cranky
we're home
be cool
i'm cool you'd be cool
[Applause]
real cool
[Music]
do
he thought i wrote it down
what a dope
[Music]
let my spirit be